[Music]
you've created in an app released it
into the wild and it's a success which
is great until its popularity crashes
your database servers resulting in
downtime loss of revenue and decreased
customer satisfaction now you're stuck
fixing database issues instead of
improving your application you could
have avoided all of this with a highly
available data persistence layer with
IBM Cloudant a JSON document database as
a service on Cloudant your data is
securely hosted and globally managed by
big data experts 24/7 IBM engineers
handle all the ongoing database
monitoring and infrastructure
maintenance so you can focus on building
your app Cloudant is optimized for web
mobile IOT and serverless applications
it's durable replication protocol is
designed to ensure that the flow of data
between the application and its database
remains uninterrupted and perform well
with high availability and fault
tolerance built into the system unlike
traditional databases all replicas of
your data are available for both reads
and writes the same data replication and
sync technology that make Cloudant
clusters so reliable allow developers to
put data closer to wherever their
applications need it most our core
storage engine is based on apache
couchdb
an open source JSON document store
Cloudant and CouchDB share a common
replication protocol which lets
developers synchronize copies of their
cloud and data to a remote CouchDB
instance at the push of a button
getting started with cloud ins managed
service is easy simply log in to the IBM
cloud and choose Cloudant from the
catalog or go to IBM comm slash cloud
slash Cloudant to sign up today